well when I first started started doing
this research and writing this book i
didn't i didn't really know very much
about insects i was actually part of the
reason why i wanted to do it you know
some are wasn't one of those kids they
spend all their time just you know
running around in nature yah always been
really a city person but you know I'm
very curious about things so I really
was very interested in trying to find
out something about them so it was sort
of amazing to me to just you know that
to just discover more and more about
about these these animals capacities and
actually to start thinking about those
animals because because people tend not
even to think about insects animals you
know at least not in the same category
to other animals so um so there were
just so many there's just so much that's
really amazing about them about their
behavior about the capacitors I mean
they can they can do such incredible
things so there was that whole side of
it there was you know the way that um
you know now I'm going blank trying to
think of things particular things that
are so interesting about well one thing
in which I talk about in the book is how
um you know that the early studies done
in the 20s which I think if still was
still being on the 7th is actually where
um people tried to figure out how many
insects they were in the air and don't
they they were figuring this out they
were interested in this because the they
were trying to track the movements of
insight pasts you know particularly ones
that were attacking cotton fields in the
in the south of the u.s. so they sent
planes up to um they send planes up to
just to try to count you know they have
these little traps under the wings and
they're they're trying to count the
insects and what they found was that
some there were just these vast numbers
of them in the air and that they were
there were a really high altitudes to
very like it 10,000 feet 15,000 feet and
what they figure out over the over the
decades they didn't really think it
realized that then at that time they
just thought that they were they'd been
sort of wrenched off by the by the air
and we're just floating around what they
figured out more recently probably from
there like 56,000 70s was that the
insects were actually deliberately
getting themselves carried away often
took off and then found air currents and
then were and then we're also able to
bring themselves down so even tiny tiny
tiny insects that that can't actually on
the
actually fly would get themselves up
into the air and would would take
themselves off places where they'd have
no more of the resources that they
wanted or just in a place that they
preferred and when they first did these
studies over Louisiana they found that
in as in a square mile I'm like a column
of air square mile there were something
like between 25 and 35 million insects
depending on the time of day in time of
year so it's a huge huge amount and so
often think about that you know when you
look out of the window that there's just
full of these things that you can't see
and that they're all going somewhere and
that they sort of i think many of they
know where they're going they're going
deliberately it's just like this
completely you know just completely
different world that's going on around
us that were almost your most of us they
just unaware of
I think what people are surprised about
is that are the cognitive abilities of
social insects so people know that they
have these these very well people tend
to think that they have people know they
have very developed social organization
they tend to think that is very rigid
and I think that's partly because um
insect social organization you know like
particularly bees and ants were you know
they were using they were used during
the Cold War to to be too as what's the
word sort of like it's an example as
metaphors allows metaphors for you know
for socialist society of communist
society so they're often been told by
tonight worker bees and workarounds and
faceless non individuals you know in
comparison to you know all those
individuals in the West so people tend
to think of them as very rigid societies
and that's actually doesn't seem to be
particularly true bees bees anyway I
think it's the same event I don't know
that much balance but but bees are
actually very flexible so although
they're in you know what what some
biologists often called casts you know
like the work worker bees and whatever
they are very flexible in terms of the
tasks that they do very adapt is so they
they actually know they'll change like
like many animals do particular fish and
fish they'll change their they'll change
their physical characteristics depending
on environmental conditions so they're
really very flexible animals and their
behavior is also quite flexible so
there's seems to be something like forty
percent of their time which is
completely unaccounted for so they'll
spend they'll be able to you know
they'll be doing all the things that we
think of as busy bees a lot of the time
but then they'll also be there's this
large almost half the time when they're
just basically just hanging around
nobody's quite sure what they're doing
all these nobody i've talked is quite
sure what they're doing they're just in
there in their hives in the dark and
they just sort of like hanging out with
each other doing stuff and still quite
clear what they're doing they don't a
lot there a lot of touching they're
doing a lot of exchanging substances
with each other a lot of social things
but nothing that seems necessarily to
have any particular function just like
most of what we do doesn't have any
particular function they just they're
just doing
Dunlop and maybe they're resting and
it's like hanging out with each other
and that that's the stuff that I think
people are less aware of because we have
these very strong stereotypes with these
rigid societies in this constant
activity and what sure that's quite like
that